everybody's sort of attacking the
scientists and that kind of tells you
who is over the target at the moment uh
here he has given a speech a couple of
this was either sad and I think this was
on Saturday uh and dealing with some
woke protesters who yeah well you know
how they are
if you looked at Governor Race's
president races 2010 12 14 16 18. yeah
thank you
um
[Applause]
you gotta have a little Spice in the
speech right I mean you got to have a
little fun
why you'd want to pay the ticket to get
in just to do that I don't know but
Different Strokes for different folks
yeah calmly coolly dealing with it as
for Jews against the santis like what
planet Are You On You Crazy this
is Florida you know how many Jews are in
Florida that used to be a joke that
there's a lot of Jews in Florida and
guess what all the Jews are still coming
down here and most of the Jews get it
and are fighting from freedom fighting
for Freedom this is the promised land
sister
by the way the reason she was protesting
was because Rhonda said this will be I
think he's doing a one day event in
Israel in Jerusalem at the end of the
month it's actually the day that I get
to Israel so I'm landing at like 7 A.M
we're going to book it to Jerusalem so I
can hopefully be there for that I'll ask
him how he feels about the Jews but I'm
pretty sure he's cool with the morons
[Music]
oh